>> [LAUGHING].
>> ANOTHER DAY ON CNN.
ANOTHER HITLER.
>> OH.
>> THINK ABOUT THE DESPICABLE
PEOPLE IN HISTORY.
I WILL USE AN EXTREME EXAMPLE.
THINK ABOUT HITLER.
YOU CAN LOOK BACK IN HISTORY
WOULD YOU SAY I AM SO GLAD THAT
PERSON WAS ALLOWED A PLATFORM SO
THEY COULD SPREAD HATE AND
PROPAGANDA AND LIES?
IT PROBABLY WASN’T THE RIGHT
THING TO DO TO SPREAD THAT.
YOU KNEW IN THE MOMENT THAT WAS
A BAD PERSON AND THEY WERE DOING
BAD THINGS.
NOT ONLY WERE THEY’RE HURTING
PEOPLE, THEY WERE KILLING
PEOPLE.
>> COMPARING ANYTHING TO AN
EXTREME LIKE HITLER WEAKENS THE
ARGUMENT.
YOU ARE TAKING A GUY WHO SAYS
THINGS YOU DON’T LIKE AND
COMPARING HIM TO A GENOCIDAL
MANIAC.
IT’S CREATING A FALSE STANDARD.
>> THEY’RE THE BEST.
>> WHEN AN ANCHOR SAID I AM
ABOUT TO USE AN EXTREME EXAMPLE,
CUT TO A COMMERCIAL.
SOMETHING IDIOTIC IS ABOUT TO BE
SAID.
IF CNN CUT TO COMMERCIAL BEFORE
EVERY STUPID THING, ALL THEY
WOULD HAVE IS CASHLESS.
-- COMMERCIALS.
CNN, COMMERCIALS, NO NEWS.
THIS IS EMOTION MASKEDS AS
THOUGHTS.
AOC CALLED HOLDING PEOPLE AT THE
BORDER CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
-- HITLER OR HOLOCAUST
COMPARISON.
IT’S THE QUICKSAND THAT EVERY
SENSIBLE PERSON AVOIDS UNLESS
THEY WORK AT CNN OR CONGRESS.
THE MEDIA IS PROTECTING THEIR
FAR LEFT IDOLS.
IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS, YOU
DIDN’T JUST DIE.
YOU DID OTHER STUFF BEFORE YOU
DIED.
RIGHT, CHRIS?
>> HERE’S THE ISSUE:
IS SHE RIGHT IN DEFINING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS?
YES, BUT DO THAT HAVE A FEELING
OF USAGE THE SAME AS WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE NAZIS AND THE
GENOCIDE OF THE JEWS.
THAT’S WHY IT’S A GREAT DEBATE.
>> NO, IT’S NOT.
WE KNOW WHAT CONCENTRATION CAMPS
MEAN.
MANY LOST FAMILY TO THEM.
WE DON’T NEED CNN LECTURING ON
SEMANTICS.
IT MOCKS THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
HOLOCAUST.
THIS IS LINKING HITLER TO TRUMP
WHICH CNN SAID IS AN EXTREME
EXAMPLE.
WHO KNOWS MORE ABOUT
ANTI-SEMITIC?
CNN OR ISRAEL?
ISRAEL DOES.
THEY JUST NAMED A TOWN TRUMP
HEIGHTS.
NOT STUPID HEIGHTS WHICH WOULD
BE A GREAT NAME IN CNN LIVED
THERE.
JUAN, WHAT I AM ABOUT TO SAY IS
EXTREME.
TURN THE CAR AROUND!
WHEN YOU SAY THAT, YOU SHOULD
SAY, IT’S A SIDELINE -- SIGN TO
GET OFF THE EXIT.
>> ON CABLE TV THAT’S NOT OUR
MO.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THE HITLER
AND HOLOCAUST COMPARISON.
>> ON THAT POINT, I AGREE
WITHUL.
INSTEAD OF HAVING THE BETTER
CONVERSATION, WHY DID TRUMP LIE
SO MUCH?
-- WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
ANALOGY AND HITLER.
>> THAT’S ALL THE LEFT HAS.
>> WELL, I DON’T KNOW.
>> WE ARE LIVING IN A GOLDEN
AGE.
>> OH, I DON’T BELIEVE THAT.
>> NANCY PELOSI AGREED WITH YOU.
TODAY SHE SAID, THIS IS STUFF
THAT THE REPUBLICANS CAN USE
AGAINST DEMOCRATS IN UPCOMING
ELECTIONS.
BUT LEMON AND CUOMO ARE RIGHT
WHEN THEY SAY PROPAGANDA AND
LIES ARE DAMAGING TO OUR
SOCIETY.
>> DANA, THE DANGEROUS THING
THAT DON LEMON IS SAYING, HE IS
COMPARING US TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMPLICIT.
LIKE OR ANYBODY WHO VOTED FOR
TRUMP OR TRIED TO EXPLAIN WHAT
TRUMP DOES IS GUILTY MUCH THE
WAY ANYBODY WHO ALLOWED HILLARY
CLINTON TO PROCEED OR GIVE HIM A
PLATFORM.
>> DO YOU THINK HE THOUGHT THAT
THROUGH?
>> NO.
>> IT MAKES SENSE TO ME.
THIS IS EXTREME.
I AGREE.
PLENTY OF OTHER THINGS TO HAVE
COVERED.
THE ISSUE WITH TALKING ABOUT THE
PROBLEM AT THE BORDER.
EVEN THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
EDITORIAL PAGE LAST WEEK UNDER
THE DEMOCRATS TO VOTE FOR THIS
MONEY THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH ASKED
FOR BECAUSE THEY DON’T HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO TAKE CARE OF
THE PEOPLE PROPERLY.
THING WHILE THEY WAIT FOR
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
CONGRESS TO CHANGE LAWS.
I DON’T KNOW IF THAT WILL
HAPPEN.
>> OKAY.
>> EMILY, SAY SOMETHING EXTREME.
ONE OF MY BIGGEST ISSUES WITH
THE REAL ISSUE AT HAND AND IT’S
THIS IS IT SHIFTS THE FOCUS FROM
ON FROM FAKE CELEBRITY FIGURE
WHO IS AAC.
-- AOC.
HE SAID THE ACADEMIC DEFINITION
IS THIS.
THAT HAS NO ISSUE WITH
CONCENTRATION CAMPS AND WORLD
WAR II.
IT’S SICKENING.
I POINT OUT, THE LEFT IS SO --
IT’S RIDICULOUS HOW THEY TREAT
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" ARTICLE
THEY SAID ONE OF AOC’S HALLMARKS
IS FIGHTING FOR IMMIGRANTS
RIGHTS AND IF THAT WAS REVERSED
THAT PERSON WOULD BE VILIFIED.
>> JESSE?
>> I WILL MAKE AN EXTREME
ANALOGY AND BACK THE CAR UP.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THE NAZI STUFF IS AN
OBSESSION WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
IT’S LAZY.
IT’S CHEAP AND IT SPEAKS TO THE
FACT THEY CAN’T CONVINCE PEOPLE
THROUGH LOGIC AND REASON THEIR
ARGUMENTS ARE EFFECTIVE.
THEY HAVE DONE THIS WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE.
IT’S THE NEXT WORLD WAR II AND
TRUMP IS HITLER AND WE ARE
RUNNING CONCENTRATION CAMPS ON
THE BORDER.
DICK DURBIN THE ILLINOIS
DEMOCRAT COMPARED SOMEONE TO
NAZIS AND ALL HELL BROKE
THROUGH.
NOW YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS RUSHING
TO DEFEND AOC.
IT’S LIKE THEY NORMALIZED THESE
NAZI AALGS.
-- ANALOGIES.
LAST MONTH THEY TRIED TO CAP THE
BED SPACE AT THE SO-CALLED
CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
THE WHOLE REASON YOU HAVE THESE
CAMPUS TO DETAIN MIGRANTS IS
BECAUSE THE LEFT DIDN’T WANT
THEM TO SEPARATE FAMILIES.
NOW THEY ARE CONCENTRATION
NOW YOU BRING THEM TOGETHER AND
CAMPS?
>> AND NOW THEY WANT MORE BEDS.
>> WHO CREATED THIS PROBLEM?
OH, MR. BULLY RHETORIC I WILL
SHUT THEM DOWN.
I WILL SHOW THEM!
>> THAT WAS UNDER OBAMA.
>> THERE IS NO RULE OF LAW IN